Before we can understand the circular economy,...
...well, it helps to define the linear economy.
Most organizations today operate in the linear economy...
...which is based on a "take, make and dispose" model.
So, for example, a light bulb company takes resources, like glass or metal,...
...to manufacture its products.
The company makes the bulb and sells it to a customer like me who uses it.
Once the light bulb burns out, I dispose of it.
It's likely neither the company nor I will ever see that light bulb again.
For a light bulb company to make money in the linear economy,...
...it tries to buy materials for the lowest cost possible...
...and to sell as many bulbs as possible.
This model operates as if there are infinite resources,...
...like glass or metal, in the world.
But you and I know that's not the case.
That's why the circular economy treats materials like they're finite.
A company in the circular economy doesn't just recycle products...
...but maintains ownership of them all along.
So the model looks more like this: make, use and return.
Let's go back to the light bulb example.
Instead of buying bulbs,...
...this office in London leases its light from Philips Lighting.
It signed a 15-year lease for the service and pays a fee each quarter.
Philips still owns the actual light bulbs...
...and provides maintenance and replacements when needed, no extra cost.
This model gives Philips the incentive to produce energy-efficient light bulbs...
...and it saves the office money with fixed lighting costs.
It's a radically different business model...
...that makes companies more like service providers than sellers of a physical product.
And it turns out, lots of companies are looking for ways to get involved.